the girag and experience but learn how
to do it correctly it's also one of the
most beneficial when it comes to your
ability to use it in a sport or any kind
of physical activity or just for regular
shit around the house being able to pick
up a couch you know being able to lift
things that are heavy
the kind of weight lifting strength that
you get from kettlebells is a full-body
strength it it's one of the one of the
best exercises for improving athletics
because when you're using something that
requires you to use your whole body to
lift then your body gets used to working
as a unit as opposed to the like the way
they used to do in the old school
bodybuilder days where some people still
do this where they isolate you know like
today I'm going to do biceps and triceps
and tomorrow I'm going to do calves
pitch such as even you're gonna have a
bunch of confused muscles that don't
know how to work together
everybody's strong but nobody speaks
each other's language you ever see like
a really big goofy bodybuilder guy try
to try to fight try throws punches of
people they fall down there all tipsy
there's a whole body's design fucked up
it's like there's too much weight up
there you ever seen one of them try and
comb their hair clean their ass ah some
of them are so big these days that they
kind of keep getting bigger I guess
that's how bodybuilding works I mean I
guess that's what it is right the
biggest guy now it's like who's the
biggest freak and those like so every
year they get bigger and bigger right
I'm I'm still in the Schwarzenegger days
of my college buddy but is it funny that
that's when they had it right that's
when they had it right like in swartz
Negritude a ton of shit too he talks
about how he did a ton of steroids but
he his physique was incredible and
impressive but not excessive in the
point that you have today you know like
today you have these guys that are just
90% steroids like you look at their body
you're just waiting for like steroids to
pull out of there fall out of their
ankles like them to be standing in a
puddle of stuff like pull up a picture
the difference between Arnold
Schwarzenegger and whoever the newest
latest mr. Olympia guy is because they
these motherfuckers just get rid does it
looks like their skin is stretched so
thin it's just gonna like burst it just
is so unreal
it's so unreal what they look like now
and get that with the black and white
ones to him bodybuilding was when he was
in his prime like look at that I mean
obviously a fucking huge huge man I mean
the dude is goddamn enormous that looks
almost like it was shooting dope does
not look fake hey we shoots a painting
it's a painting it's a painting right
it's hard to see in this resolution when
that's real that's legit what is this
click for full resolution oh it's one of
those stupid websites but they deal with
that's why you never want to get all
sports nigger famous well look at every
website it's just a scam and they click
on it like the one scroll down there
scroll down there do oh no no no a
little little further little further a
little further a little further down
there's some yeah like get those ones if
that one right there of him on stage his
arms stretched out with all the people
behind him yeah there you get a good
image okay Jesus Christ okay but perfect
example because holy shit was he fucking
enormous right but not compared to today
not you know ridiculous
you decided dude that big today on the
street yeah or in the UFC elderly well
not really I guess sort of like glaze
and t bow is pretty fucking big but not
built like that I mean that's just one
image of Arnold he was pretty fucking
massive there's a few guys that are big
like Tyron Woodley who's a badass
welterweight he's real big but not like
that
it's a different kind of big they're
like they're like super athlete big this
is like a different thing this is like
all this for some nigger 6-1 6-2 I think
I'm Adam I'm not um recently at the UFC
it was cool as fuck oh you're doing
doing an excellent job let's like thank
you I think it even cited like I'm
holding hands with Arnold fucking Swartz
and Egger I'm like this is crazy no
waiting on no prize with Arnold so here
the current I'm a fan there's the
current chi-town
I guess Muffy's muscles have muscles my
god that guy's fucking - tick asleep IgG
it's like there's muscles that don't
even exist there I'm like you've got
hand muscles look just hand muscles have
you ever seen anybody with hand muscles
like that
there's more muscles in his hand than
there are in my torso let me just tell
you one thing that that guy works hard
no doubt about it ladies and gentlemen
that guy does a lot of lifting and does
everything scientifically incorrect but
what's fucked up is you can't even get
there without steroids you can't get
there you can't get there that doesn't
exist that's not a destination on your
navigation system his muscles look like
they need to be ironed they look
wrinkled the only way you get that big
without the juice you have to be on the
skin is so much that's what those lines
are like the skin looks like you could
just tear it yes that's the striations
of the muscle tissue underneath the skin
the skin is just so thin because they're
kureta incredibly dehydrated not just
low on fat not just massive amounts of
muscle but insanely dehydrated that's
not possible without a bunch of
different factors and that look is
extremely unhealthy that's really more
performance art to me than it is like a
sport oh my I got the light when I was
competing in Taekwondo tournaments I got
down to four and a half body weight four
and a half percent body weight body fat
by a caliper now I've been told recently
the Dutch shit is not very accurate like
calipers like you really got to get
dunked underwater or do electrical thing
so you know I I said four and a half
percent and a bunch of people corrected
me thank you for correcting me because I
didn't know that the calipers were so
bad but that's what they told me so like
that would probably be like 7% or
something like that if I was super super
lean but nothing compared to these guys
what these guys are doing I was I was
working out what these guys are doing is
like getting real close to death while
keeping giant muscles it's fucking
madness like this is the nuttiest
fucking sport of all time
yes performance art here this that guy
will rip your dick clean off it was ask
doors those bank vault ass doors of his
just looks like Jar Jar Binks um on
accom oh and I see we don't sell
steroids
[Music]
you